au coeur de marseille ce théâtre à
braver l'interdît hier en ouvrant ses
portes pour un moment des changes avec
l'une de ses comédiennes et auteur de
one woman show audrey vernon le théâtre
la rhd ainsi fait écho à un cri de
colère celui du directeur de la factory
à avignon qui a appelé à ouvrir pendant
une heure tous les théâtres et lieux de
culture ce samedi une quarantaine de
théâtre en france ont répondu présent
l'idée de participer donc pour ma part
c'est pas forcément dans un esprit
rebelle c'est juste battent déjà pour
ouvrir nos portes pour le moral ça fait
du bien déjà premièrement la le
l'occasion était trop belle donc pour
dire à tout l'état de france avec
n'oublierai en signe de protestation
deux pour montrer un petit peu
l'absurdité de la situation actuelle on
veut vraiment rappeler qu'il n'ya pas
deux il ya jamais eu aucun cluster dans
aucun théâtre de france jusqu'à présent
tout est gratuit ce jour là la
conférence comme les boissons
pour les organisateurs il s'agit avant
tout de partager de retrouver le public
les lieux de culture et d'intelligence
soit fermée c'est très inquiétant est le
fait qu'il n'y ait plus que des endroits
marchand où on est le droit d'aller ça
aussi c'est très inquiétant c'est on
dirait qu'il ya plus d espace de
gratuité finalement de discussion je me
rends compte à quel point les
interactions sociales et humaines sont
importantes au niveau de la santé du
bien-être
le spectacle d'eau de rêveur non
biglione dollar baby était programmée au
théâtre fin 2019 mais n'a pu être joué
en raison du couvre feu puis du second
confinement en attendant de retrouver
officiellement son public
la comédienne a pu partager avec lui un
moment des changes mêlant humour et
engagement las d'être sur scène
aujourd'hui enfin c'est super je suis
très contente
et puis surtout je suis très contente
qui est de théâtre en france qu'ils
fassent ça
qui ouvrent leurs portes dans une
démarche totalement non marchandes ça
aussi je trouve ça important dans la
salle une vingtaine de spectateurs sont
venus pour soutenir la culture exprimé
leur besoin d'art et d'évasion mais
aussi pour manifester leur désaccord
avec la politique sanitaire
c'est un rappel pour nous de dire sans
la culture
mais effectivement il ya beaucoup de
gens qui commencent à se sentir un petit
peu en détresse et surtout quand ça fait
partie de moi ça fait partie de mon mode
de vie de faire une halte de sorties
culturelles par semaine et va 100 ça je
me retrouve à gens trouvent de la
culture mais j'suis pas nourri de la
même façon on se rend compte que que la
culture va mal et que malgré tous les
efforts d'aidé des directeurs des
responsables aujourd'hui la culture est
en train de mourir à petit feu et et
voire même sacrifié tout en sachant que
c'est pas forcément les lieux où y aller
les plus forte contamination voire
quasiment pas quoi
chaque participant risquer une amende de
135 euros
le gérant s'exposant lui à 1500 euros de
pénalités accompagné d'une fermeture
administrative de son établissement